[Music]
hey
you
listener it's the pill pod of pills me
together with eric
yo can you identify yourself when i say
your name
eric here
victor
here
and that's all we have with us today
what about what about mcmanus sorry matt
power of air
what if mcmanus um we haven't done that
in a while so if there's anyone who who
doesn't know who's who
now
everything's been cleared up you could
just cut this and put this as our
permanent intro you trying to get us to
like acknowledge our existence great you
are listening to the pill pod which is
something that we do on fridays and we
do it on wednesdays sometimes thursdays
critical theory
philosophy
today's philosophy real real ass
philosophy
yeah and we got to get this done quick
so that we can uh play aoe4
age of empires sorry eric do you have
age of empires yet no
i don't know if it'll work for my
computer man
i built this thing for work not for
games
you mean you built it shittily
i mean video cards right now are
fuckered so i can't afford it that's
impossible they are
extremely expensive
i've been on a waitlist for one year
yeah it's crazy it's because of crypto
[ __ ] yeah the crypto mining plus uh
i think just kovid disruptions i i did i
built one with an intel card with a
built-in uh video card it's it's not too
bad
it it gets the basic the indie games i
can play i don't know if i can play
those uh aaa slave labor games like uh
aoe
if i'm not mistaken uh i think like
there's like yeah the semiconductor
shortage it's like the other so it's
like that combined with crypto it's just
destroying it i think we should just do
the critical theory thing and blame
capitalism we'll just say it's
capitalism
[ __ ] easy answer yeah easy religious
answer so today we are not we are not
talking about capitalism at all
maybe if we wanted to sound more
sophisticated we could say it's all
neoliberalism's fault that's the kind of
vogue way of saying it's all
capitalism's fault okay so exactly
capitalism i mean they sound like the
same thing to me much more nuanced it is
friday
or your current temporal horizon intends
from a friday november 5th indeed but
that friday will forever have been
actualized if you're listening to this
after friday november 5th but for us it
is wednesday november 3rd
so we have a different temporal horizon
intending towards friday which has not
happened yet now what does all this mean
it means
we are
at long last covering phenomenology
yay
the good stuff we've been bouncing
around a bit for the last month doing
short stories shows books mostly so that
we could read up on this
um an extended series when we get back
to the text at length the
phenomenological text
the text of real life not politics
not metaphysics like we were arguing
about about a month ago delisian versus
uh hegelian metaphysics but now it's
back to real life
and yeah we're gonna stick with it
i've been pushing this for a while every
time we were like what are we gonna do i
say phenomenology
and then someone comes up with something
uh more pressing
yeah i'm i'm happy we're doing
phenomenology it's one of the main uh
i guess my main strengths you know i
don't i'm not gonna feel like uh like
like a like i'm out of my league like
when we try to talk about de las or
dereda well the tables have turned on me
because it's not my strong suit
but i feel like i have a a decent
sense of phenomenology in general
i know matt does because he took my book
but look what he did to my book
can you see the spine
oh it's broken
i i hate i hate lending out my books for
this reason but i feel bad not because
then they're just sitting there doing
nothing
but at least he didn't get like he
didn't get dorito dust all over it so
i'm thankful for that or any other dude
any other types of stains
i mean
don't look at page 223
i was going through a bad coke addiction
at that point so if you happen to graze
off a little white powder
cheese
therapy is did he mark it up at all with
pencil no he didn't thank thank you matt
for having me do you know
you never mark up your books
no i never do that uh the most i'll do
is i'll sometimes
write down quotations from the text that
i think are particularly germane usually
with a reference number but the reality
is that i'm such an academic now that
the main reason i read text is like okay
at some point or another i'm going to
need to reference this section for this
work in this particular journal article
or book or whatever it happens to be so
that's what i look for you know the
juicy statements
god i love marking up my books
not my library books my books
yeah yeah i i save my pen for the
library books
did i say what book matt borrowed it's
the phenomenology of perception
but we're doing
we're doing phenomenology generally so
it might incorporate some
like kant to husserl to
heidegger
um but we're gonna do it but we're gonna
do it topically instead of by text so
today we're doing
life world the actual world actual life
um and the gui center i think that most
of us are going to refer to is maurice
merluponti
maurice
and what prompted this
as road as it sounds we should just
start we should just start with what
prompted this yeah good idea
as road as it sounds
we live in a media saturated culture
so
we
as individuals
maybe matt's different but the rest of
us have not long been media saturated
because
grad school somewhat cloisters you from
whatever counts as theory on social
media
but speaking for myself
having been a
an internet denizen for two years
regularly i'm starting to go a little
bit insane
understandably and the cure for insanity
and the cure for
disembodied anime avatars arguing about
guttari
is none other than this man maurice
merlupanti and the embodied life world
so please pay attention
we will save your soul by the end of
this series i also wonder whether this
series is inspired by the uh another
wrote thing the the sudden
alienation from all of our social
relations that covet has inflicted upon
us
phenomenology is a way of getting back
to
some relation to something right
relation to the world around you
relation to
the objects around you how you perceive
them
i think
what inspired this is also a kind of
desire for to present philosophy in a
way that it can actually
help your life and be relevant to you
when you go out into the world and not
just be like a kind of david hume hobby
horse
where he does it in his attic
and it all sounds great but when he goes
into the marketplace it makes no
difference whatsoever because
common sense trumps
philosophical speculation when it comes
to living your life so phenomenology is
a way of getting back
into the world and relating to it in a
new way
since covid
and other climate related things are
slowly alienating us from our wider
social networks
and maybe our uh our sorts of long-held
habitual relations to
the weather and the animals and
that sort of stuff the odd thing is
that's the primary thesis of the book
that i have that's coming out in a few
months the emergency postmodernity that
the emerge that the time consciousness
of neoliberal prosperity is primarily
phenomenological in part for that reason
so it's timely i agree wait what
what are you saying is phenomenological
the oh the main thesis of my new book
that's coming out and i guess five or
six months whenever they decide to
announce it is that postmodernity
generates its own distinctive time
consciousness uh which is primarily
phenomenological and orientation in part
because phenomenology offers a kind of
way out of the isolation uh that many
people feel within the conditions of
neoliberal capitalism as kind of a
historicism yeah using a lot of words
that i said we weren't going to i think
i think my general presentation uh
triggered that association in matt's
mind and so well i'm curious when you
say that it's phenomenological what do
you mean by the word phenomenological oh
that's what we got to get into isn't it
the primary argument that i make is that
uh there's been kind of a movement
towards an individuated conception of
ecstatic time that defines the
neoliberal subject
as a way of trying to gain a kind of
authenticity within the context of
post-modernity uh but i'm also critical
of it by saying that what we need to do
is move away from a phenomenological
time consciousness the one that's more
dialectical um
historically minded if you want to call
it that
i mean uh yeah
i see um yeah i'm not sure well we'll
we'll get into that i'm not sure if i if
i if yeah
that sounds like uh fertile ground for a
lot of disagreement because i don't like
a lot of what you just said yeah because
it sounds like you're kind of con it
kind of sounds like you're conflating
phenomenology with like individualism
and that just that seems wrong to me but
it's not necessarily individualistic in
the sense that um it applies a retreat
into a myopic view of the world
so much as its retreat towards
a
desire for phenomenological meaning uh
in the extensive life world that we have
with other people that's primarily
framed in terms of self-creation uh and
a yearning for authenticity in the part
of our social on the part of ourselves
and in our yearning for social relations
that are also authentic
fair enough but i do i take issue with
calling that phenomenological but anyway
we're getting we're getting off track
here i like phenomenology because of its
objects oriented sort of basic it's this
basic to its stance is it's very
object-oriented
it's very practical
it's very sort of
not not necessarily here and now there's
some weird ways of talking about time
and space but it is very much
about our involvement with things in the
world and our i mean at least with ponte
our having a body and our subjectivity
sort of implying
a body that interposes itself between us
and the world and it's equipped with all
sorts of ways of understanding the world
that
we kind of have to understand first
before we get to the objects themselves
but that was kind of
husserl's i guess original
phenomenological call right get back to
the to the objects themselves
is that that's that sort of sounds right
doesn't it so today we are not being
precise this is important we will get
precise later on but today we're just
going to mash up a bunch of concepts
from who cyril heidegger and merlo ponti
and just call it all
life world
so they all use similar concepts and
words uh horizon
comes up a lot but in the end it amounts
to more or less the same explanatory
structure of phenomenology which is how
do we experience the world
and the life world is the space in which
objects appear to us we also appear to
objects
and we also appear to ourselves
yeah i think i mean the translation that
i had i think is that the same thing as
the phenomenal field the field right not
quite close
he says horizontal often also i i think
it's milieu in french
i think the field the field and the
horizon are yeah there there's something
to get a hold of because that was
confusing me a little bit but you know
that's all over heidegger too right the
horizon of our understanding so it is it
is historical in that way when you talk
about the horizon of understanding
because you know when you're when you're
reading an old book or something when
i'm reading dante i'm trying to fuse my
horizon of understanding which is sort
of cultural and historical and specific
to me
and with dante's which is a whole other
world i got to learn about guelphs and
gibbolines and medieval florence and
it's it's a
so there is there's the historical there
it's not dialectical maybe
i'm not up to matt's standards but it's
uh maybe maybe uh it is that way though
so let's let me first just say what is
what is a horizon what is the metaphor
for
um a horizon just means a limit it means
the edge the border
um what what you see appears within the
horizon what you can't see which you
assume still exists appears outside of
the horizon so you are together with
things as they come to be
within your horizon and what's outside
the horizon you don't know when
something new appears in your horizon
then you sort of have to adapt and
adjust to it so that it makes sense with
all the other stuff that's in there and
that's kind of the way that all three of
them
use the the analogy
analogy or metaphor i think it's a i
think it's a metaphor because horizon is
you know it's got that horizontal in it
you should hear the resonance of
horizontal there and where do we find a
horizon i'm not sure if this is correct
but in
painting right in perspectival painting
and perspective is going to come a lot
up quite a lot so you have your horizon
your horizon line where the sky meets
the ground and you can't see anything
beyond that
and all and then you have your focal
point where all the lines that go into
the space of the image tend to meet at
that point if you're using mathematical
one-point perspective but the horizon is
i think a metaphor may be transposed
over from renaissance painting into
philosophy
to denote you know the edge of our
understanding kind of thing right as far
you know our historical horizon
is
what we can understand versus what's
kind of
lost to the past
and then the spatial horizon is kind of
a little more literal maybe in that
sense i should say condition
well i was going to say i'm i'm confused
because like like it so you're saying
that in mayor laponte there's a
phenomenal horizon i mean the the main
concept so is that different than like
his idea of like that we that we get
experience as a gestalt as like one
thing that is the phenomenal field
is the form right the horizon structure
he talks about
is something different so the phenomenal
field is the term that i'm i'm i'm i'm
familiar with i was looking for a
phenomenal horizon but i don't oh i see
what you're saying
yeah the horizons well there are inner
and outer horizons your attention has an
inner horizon that's the the phenomenon
that is limited by your attention at a
moment but then there's also the general
horizon which is the limit of what you
can experience so murlou ponti also
discusses temporal horizons
uh in which the past appears in the
present that would be something like
memory but it's also a little tough to
be faithful because we're reading in
english husserl is writing in german
merlou ponti and french and heidegger in
his own made up language so it'd be a
lot more meticulous to try to line up
these terms one to one but in english
yeah we get field i think part of the
problem is
the original uh husserlian notion uh of
the life world uh actually emerged very
late in his own phenomenological project
um it's actually quite interesting
because cereal was far less dogmatic and
some points that heidegger occasionally
accuses him of because the
phenomenological project started
adjacent if you want to call it to the
neocantium project of resuscitating
idealism except insisting that we move
towards things in themselves as eric put
it and there was this kind of cartesian
flavor
to early hysterianism that was
criticized by people like heidegger who
saw it as too beholden to the philosophy
of the subject and later on her sorrow
moves towards characterizing the life
world as something that's created far
more by the intersubjective processes of
meaning formation that people engage
with um and interestingly enough that's
the kind of conception of life world
that's later picked up by sociologists
um and social commentators like habermas
theory of communicative action is
actually really centered on this idea
that the life world has been colonized
uh by the neoliberal capitalist order uh
and needs to be liberated from this
right yeah uh and from the perspective
of
a kind of discourse theorist like
habermas uh one of the problems with a
kind of pontia notion of the
phenomenological spirit field as it's
still too wrapped up uh in the
philosophy of subjectivity um i don't
think that's really fair but there's big
debates that go on with uh within the
circle around that you know uh is the
life world in history i'm gonna have to
ask you to speak english because we're
on we're on day one of phenomenology
sorry sorry yeah so i mean there's
basically this
sure there's basically this idea that
you find in the late hurster uh the
crisis of the european sciences where he
responds to heidegger by saying there is
some truth to this idea that the notion
of the life world as created by the
individual or as giving meaning to the
individual is hugely problematic and so
many of the meanings that we ascribe to
the objects around us are set by things
like language history culture
scientific discourse you name it right
we're jumping ahead a little bit there
try to take this step by step let's just
start with object
let's start with objects i agree i mean
i think that like that is like the one
of the puzzles i think the other puzzle
like is
like why do like so if we have this i
think there's like a tension between
um sort of like thinking about
subjectivity as like a rational subject
in the sense that like i mean obviously
that the like the debates you know kind
of rationalism or empiricism like how is
our consciousness
um like
why are objects appearing the way that
they are to us and like you know they're
with ideas that oh we must be judging
there to be like a behind
but i think like the point of of using
phenomenology to notice like the horizon
or
phenomenal field is to be like well
actually when you like pay attention you
see that like you're not doing any
rational calculation a lot of the time
like things are just soliciting you uh
that there's like a behind to that glass
that you're looking at or something like
that and i think like
the puzzle is part of it part of the
puzzle anyways like well why is it like
what explains the fact that like
we don't have to like use our faculty of
judgment or something like that to
figure out uh what's behind or something
yeah so we we
if we're doing even the beginning of uh
phenomenology proper
we have all these answers to what
objects are and really what hostile's
trying to figure out in merlot ponte
after
is how do we get an idea of a thing in
our head
and merlou ponte wants to kind of clear
the table of
descartes version of how we get an idea
in our head and even hume's version of
how a whole bunch of senses turn into an
idea and he's just saying let's look at
how we look at stuff
we'll just talk about the water bottle
we'll talk about the water bottle for
the rest of the
episode how does water bottle get from
my desk into my mind
and and what happens to it
as you move around it as you take it in
from different perspectives
and relate it to the sort of objects
around it right
the circulatory system probably plays a
big role in that
my blood i i and my my blood does i i
think when i use the term horizon what i
just tend to mean is
at the largest level it's the world it's
the background against which objects
appear
right so another way to talk about this
is in terms of figure ground
right so you're just kind of lazily
scanning around you you're not really
looking at anything in particular
there's a load of things soliciting your
attention and attention is key here but
you don't really pay your attention to
any of those objects and suddenly
something you're interested in for some
reason or other right we don't want to
claim there's some kind of rational
origin of our interests but
it just kind of is the way it is
sometimes you're interested in something
you focus on it
suddenly
a horizon kind of appears which consists
of all the other objects that fade into
the backgrounds that are concealed and
the object in the foreground the one
that you are
paying your attention to the one you're
focusing on so horizon is kind of
relative to that
whole situation but then at the largest
sense when we're talking about horizon
in general it really is our sort of
historical spatial world
the background
of
objects in a sense right it's the whole
through which
objects
are parts
right we understand objects as parts of
holes or as nodes of systems he kind of
talks about the system of objects right
that
then recedes into the background this
action of of moving
scanning paying attention to
and and repetition of that process
is is perception right when we
we don't perceive from a static
point in space we move we're constantly
on the move there's things happening
there's stuff going on around us that's
fighting for our attention the clamor
of being i don't know whose phrase that
is well also it's also what's also kind
of interesting is like our attention
doesn't even
it gets drawn in a way that seems
kind of
um
not not quite unconscious but like not
really like effortfully intentional
right it's like that's why i think mira
laponte in particular uses this language
of solicitation at least in the english
translation right that like objects in
the world they solicit you like the the
spatiality of an object
solicits you to just like feel
uh perceive that there is like another
side to it um it's not like a mystery to
you right you're not like hmm i wonder
if there is another side or if i just
have like a 2d image and like that's all
there is like it's just the world just
is pulling you
to wards like this this this spatiality
this like this potentiality of a world
and it also is soliciting utep and this
is kind of what the intro is about at
least part of it is like
there's also this feeling that the
object itself has uh as you said like a
kind of wholeness to it a kind of like
stability to it like it just seems like
it is like a stable object uh even
though all you have are like
perspectives on it but it's still
there's still something about it that
solicits you to be like that's an object
that is like a stable thing
okay how does that happen
i think this is where you see
phenomenology really differ from
earlier um figures who are concerned
with similar issues right particularly
imperial uh imperialism i am too
political uh pierce is so political
particularly
empiricism uh and what he calls
intellectualism right which is just a
kind of fancy name for pantianism uh
since one of the interesting things
about this is
both the major empiricists from walk to
hume and then kant
all say that we're going to talk a lot
about how experience becomes possible
but they never actually really talk
about the objects that people experience
there's this tremendous concern for
what prefigures the possibility of any
kind of experience whether it's the
capacity of the human mind to link the
memories of experience together uh to
create the possibilities for perception
over the appearances or it's this grand
transcendental architecture that can't
conceive those in defense pure reason uh
that preconditions the possibility of
experience but in none of these kind of
circumstances do we actually talk about
something that possibly both think is
much more immediate which is just what
it actually feels like kinesthetically
to experience something right and i
think it's a very very good point
because you can scour lock and hume and
can't and you very rarely ever hear them
talk about to use pills metaphor water
bottle what it's like to see water
bottle feel a water bottle to taste
water you know running down your throat
none of that ever really appears because
they're always saying we can't even get
to that yet
and what's refreshing about the
phenomenologist they say well why don't
we just
start by talking about that what's it
like to actually exist and experience
these things maybe not directly but to
experience them as a kind of subject
so i promised this was about
the real world
i'm watching because i can see on my
screen this also applies to
uh your ears as well not just your eyes
but i'm watching
people talk i look at eric while eric's
talking then victor and matt disappear
for me then victor starts talking my
water bottle kind of disappears it
becomes a background
and for merlou ponte it's that
background that allows one thing to pop
into
attention or your your intention
so my water bottle keeps disappearing
because i'm focusing on other stuff but
i can still see everything in the room
around me it's just that they are not
soliciting
attention at that time and even
listener wherever you're at you're just
doing this uh with your ears
um you might be driving you might be
uh cleaning up your apartment
and you're you're doing all of that but
that fades into the background while
you're listening to one of us idiots uh
give our spiel on this so your attention
is solicited but that's not your whole
world the world allows that little bit
of attention to appear as intentional
yeah exactly i think to go back to our
earlier episode on a.i uh this is why
phenomenology has a lot to say that's
critical of kind of rationalistic uh or
empiricist conceptions of how it is that
consciousness works because again both
of them are so fixated on the background
conditions for the emergence of anything
like a conscious entity to emerge
usually understood in these very formal
terms whereas the phenomenologist will
say well what about being an
intentionalist being that's invested in
the world right uh that means having a
certain kind of care in what's going on
which is precisely why certain things
appear to you as more significant than
others right you're thirsty you see
water bottle and it appears as water
bottle to you i want to have a
conversation with victor or eric and
they are foregrounded in my perception
in a way that the background isn't yeah
and i think
what victor said is very important about
this idea of intention
right because sometimes we slip into
this way of thinking where
when we are you know
attending to an object
when we're perceiving an object right
that there's somehow some kind of
rational intentional stance underlying
that attention
that it's almost like a propositional
kind of
thing you know
the way we're about something that
consciousness is about something
but what ponti wants to do is he wants
to get back into the preconceptual
pre-propositional even pre-linguistic
kind of
aspect of of perception
and
so the solicitation
is kind of important here because it is
sort of pre-intentional it's not
our our intentions are not the ground of
our perception right intentions in a
sense come
later or after
i think those those sorts of
preconceptual aspects of perception that
merlot ponte wants to get at are exactly
what underlies the intentional stance
so it's something not to start with but
it's something
to
understand is in there
but that's it's the kind of confusing
part of getting away from both
rationalism and empiricism with
phenomenology right as empiricism wants
to build up from impressions that are
simply just copies of the sensations
that sort of hit hit us from outside in
experience right and build up from
impressions and talk about the laws of
association
and that's the empiricist kind of
explanatory apparatus right and then the
rationalists have their own explanatory
apparatus or if you want to talk about
cognitivists you have kant right where
he's going to focus more on the mind's
contribution to our perception of
objects right uh the categories of the
understanding and the rules
of the understanding now phenomenology
brushes both of those things aside
and says let's because those those are
both right wrong
for ponte right empiricist no our our
ideas in our mind are not simply just
copies of sensations outside us the
things in our head look nothing like the
things in the world and that it's silly
to assume that they do and on the
rationalist side right when you're
focusing on the contribution of the mind
to the object you get into all sorts of
other problems in relation to that as
well i mean give me a few years and i'll
get the picture right
yeah sure it sounds like it sounds like
what you're describing is i mean another
way of putting it is to like the kind of
debate or tension between like
representationalism versus non-wreck
because and i think marilla ponte and
phenomenology is ultimately like an
account of non-representational
uh that like are at base our engagement
with the world is non-representational
and when i say representational i mean
that like a representationalist view
would be like we have a propositional
idea or like an image in our head that
when we when we're like looking for
something for example like we'll have
like or when we're engaging with
something in the world it's like we have
some representation of that thing that
lets us recognize that thing and then we
are able to engage with it because we
have
that representation of it somehow in our
mind and a non-representationalist view
is like well no no like you don't really
have these like rational propositional
images in your mind or like ideas in
your mind but you just are engaging with
the world with on a bunch of like there
are obviously like thoughts that are
kind of like image based or whatever but
there but but also like that's why the
body is important for marilyn ponty
right like like drawing attention the
body the whole point of it is to be like
our engagement with the world is not
predicated on representations in our in
our brain
because we're forgetting the body when
we do that there's like a whole layer of
like and i would i like to think of it
as almost like our body schema which is
a term that's used in at least one of
the translations of the phenomenology
perception gets like reconfigured so
like our sensitivities to the world i
like to think of it almost in in terms
of like sensitivities that we are
sensitive to certain things in the world
where they will draw our attention and
that thing will become in the foreground
rather than the background and though
the reason for those sensitivities those
shifts and sensitivities have to do with
a bunch of factors that are social and
habitual that we'll get to later in the
series but that's one way of thinking
about it yeah maybe attunements to
certain things or something
like like a tuning fork
just before i'd like just before i'd
like to reiter eric and victor actually
just said the same thing it might not
sound like it but i want to put it in as
simple as possible terms so everyone
knows exactly where we are
the one idea is if we have a whole bunch
of sensations we see color
we see something shiny
we see black we see liquid
how is it that these perceptions of my
water bottle by the way
turn into water bottle
first of all i have to be expecting it
to turn into a water bottle i can't just
be receiving impressions and then it
turns into that because for merlou ponte
the empiricist can't explain that and on
the other side the rationalists are like
no there's an idea of water bottle and
then
those are conformed
somehow to the outside world so we're
really trying to figure out how the idea
corresponds to
things that exist outside of us that we
experience
and one is on one side saying the idea
is in your head and everything and
the actual sensations don't matter and
one's saying there is no idea it's just
sensations
so he's trying to bridge that gap and
that's what we're going to be
going on about for the rest of the time
and i want to point out how radical this
idea is uh ponte is a very humble
thinker in a lot of ways you can see
that in the way that he really engages
extraordinarily thoroughly with what it
takes to be the primary competing
positions uh empiricism and
intellectualism to his own uh but in a
certain sense you could construct a
genealogy in pontian terms to say that
the biggest problem with western
philosophy
goes all the way back to somebody like
plato uh for whom the problem of
representation poses itself precisely
because the body it so easily deceives
us into getting an accurate vision of
the world so the trick has to be to get
as dissociated from the body and its
experiences as possible think about the
metaphor of the cave and moving up to
the heavens uh and pontius implies
sometimes that you can see this platonic
prejudice carry through the whole
history of philosophy no matter western
philosophy no matter how far people get
away from plato you see it in block you
see it in kent and he's the first one to
say you will never solve this problem of
representation or indeed if you want to
put it with capital t
the truth of the world by dissociating
from the body in this way and pretending
like it's a problem because we are
invested in the world as bodily beings
that leaves birth to the intentional
status with dance which makes perception
possible so we need to take the body
very seriously as an object of
theoretical inquiry rather than just
denouncing it uh and he's this
wonderfully funny and remarkably french
uh
joke somewhere where he says the most
offensive thing about the body to many
philosophers has been the fact that
people [ __ ] and [ __ ] and spit and that
all seems low whereas i'm going to tell
you if you didn't do those things you
wouldn't be where you are right now uh
so stop being embarrassed by the body
embrace it and take it seriously
filthy i like it
and another way of saying that is when
you have
a view i don't i don't want to [ __ ] on
plato because i i think it's too foreign
but we can maybe [ __ ] on someone like
descartes
if you have this vision
and i think people take this a little
bit common sense that there's an
objective world and science knows it
and or just a a world that is true a
true world that we might be wrong about
we might be right about it but there is
something out there
and for merlou ponte that's fine that we
conceive of that but the only reason
that we can conceive of that is because
we do have bodies that are so familiar
with the world they're so stuck in it
that we can actually dissociate and
pretend like we weren't stuck there like
the example i like to use is if you you
might be listening to this while you're
driving think of what a complex
behavior and system of habits driving is
you're you could if you make a mistake
you could kill yourself or kill somebody
but it's almost like it's nothing
to you you can listen to
a bunch of nerds talk about philosophy
while you're driving and not kill
anybody
so the fact that that can happen means
you're already so used to the world and
that's because you grew up in it you
don't you're not born able to drive but
because you have all these interactions
you build up
what we're calling a life world that
you're you can engage with as a second
nature without thinking about it without
being conscious of it without making
rational judgments about it
yeah one of the things that merlot ponte
does that's really spectacular uh just
to say i think sartre around the same
period does a good job of this uh in his
novels especially he says think about
the way that the world as you understand
it and contemplated intellectually is
designed precisely for
bodily entities like us you know i wake
up in bed i'm lying down flat because i
have a back and this is a biological
necessity for me i get up and there's a
door handle that's about level with my
hand and i open it that way you know i
go into the kitchen and i pour myself a
glass of water and there's a handle on
my mug because again i have fingers and
digits and all that stuff
uh and again you do so much of this
unconsciously without ever really
thinking about how we could have a very
differently structured world if we had a
very different body
the geometry of social space as it
presents itself would have to be
entirely reconfigured
and i found the book really refreshing
because that's such a puzzling way to
think about things
that it really
compels you to ask yourself how many
instances of this you can see and it's
really
amazing
how much depends on us having the bodies
that we happen to have in terms of our
politics architecture aesthetics you
name it right
yeah i also think like you know what's
important about about this kind of
account too is you know i still think if
there's like you know there's a specter
of like the older empiricist
rationalist conception of the human
being always in the background i feel
like i feel like when we talk about
anything
uh like anything social even
philosophical you know i think that
there's that specter of like i guess
you know there's different versions of
it you know like even in economics
there's like the rational actor right
which which plays like a role in
economics and there's and like i think
in politics when we talk about i mean
even in like marxism there's like this
idea that like you know you're going to
find your class interest and then you're
going to like you're going to act or
whatever and i mean there's nuances
there and there's like ways of reading
those things that could maybe be
consistent but in general i think like
there is in the background of philosophy
of things that we care about politics
which you know we're not going to talk
about today that like you know even
radical politics that that there is an
implication of a kind of
rationalist view of the human being that
like we are more in control and more
aware of like what we are intentionally
doing and that there's more possibility
to like intentionally do things
differently and get out of kind of being
stuck in certain ways of thinking and
ways of being in the world
that um forget i think like the
phenomenological view of the human being
and our bodies and the kind of
limitations that the body and like the
ways that the world is structured for us
as a consequence
of our bodies um
i think that is forgotten and ignored or
like claims are made that ignore it
yeah i just so that people don't think
i'm i want to [ __ ] on marilla ponte
because of what i said earlier on about
my critique of phenomenology uh he was a
radical leftist he wrote for laton
mandan uh described himself as kind of
part of the anti-communist left so if he
were actually to have a conversation
about
politics i imagine that most of us would
probably broadly agree uh with some of
what he said in fact he probably
wouldn't be liberal enough for me so
no problem with him on that front
you know if you do try to publish that
thesis that that we need to step away
from phenomenology i'm going to do a
full live stream taking down your book
[Laughter]
one of those views about the human are
always in the background because they
are part of our sort of historical
horizon of understanding right the
enlightenment
and the scientific revolution and those
sorts of things are always in the
background of our philosophizing and our
phenomenological experience
those things just it's not like for
instance it's not that it's not that
ponte doesn't like science is that he
just thinks that
many of us are doing it wrong or have a
backward way of looking at science
as something as the as that again
view from nowhere
right where you can see an object but
from no perspective in particular
which is actually almost to see it from
every perspective at once
and i i get the sense that
the phenomenologist thinks of that as as
sort of impossible right because you
always have a perspective you always
have
a measure of of time and space
over which your perception unfolds and
it's always a process of unfolding
in those terms within your horizon and
so
it's kind of science that tries to
deny the existence of a body for
instance is a science that's gone
very very wrong
and into a kind of objectivist stance
right with all the sorts of assumptions
and problems that brings
along with it and the phenomenologists
rather emphasizes again our our
involvement in the world and our
throneness in the world
and our sort of very partial
view of the world where our
gaze our gaze our our looking at things
has always intermingled with other gazes
and even the gazes of the object right
when i look at a house and i see another
house behind it
it's almost in a strange way like that
that house behind the one i'm looking at
has a view
of the house that i'm looking at
that i don't have i have to adjust my
position just for uh just for our
listeners eric does like to stalk his
neighbors every now and then that's what
the telescope in his room is for yeah
he's got a nice balcony for looking into
his neighbor's windows exactly and i
always have to look through the glass
and then take it down off my head for a
second to see what i'm looking at
i like i look and i zoom in and i say oh
there's a nice pair of boobs and then i
take them down it's actually a guy
bending over in the fridge and his butt
cracks hanging out so it's always
important to change your perspective
to have it adaptive to time yeah one of
the great quotes in this is uh each
object is the mirror of every other
and part of this view from everywhere
his example is a house my example is a
water bottle even though you can't ever
see
the whole thing at the at the same time
you can always imagine
what it looks like from the other side
but then we string together these
imaginations and then say if we could
see from everywhere
that would be a complete view but it's
impossible to see from everywhere that's
the point so you mentioned our cases
would have to penetrate into the object
right through insides and everything
about it like almost like an x-ray
vision so the total view the total view
is an imaginary view is what he's kind
of yeah
well it's kind of virtual like so like
like
so but but like that's true but then
like the question that the
phenomenologist asked is like yeah of
course so we can't see the things from
the uh from like all sides but that but
yet we still get this sensation of like
getting the whole object right right
right so like it doesn't actually feel
like we're missing out that's the puzzle
right and that's where the prejudice of
the idea also comes from exactly but
then we think that the idea is the
actual thing and that's the mistake
exactly exactly
i think to go back to this kind of
genealogical account of the history of
western thought you can see elements of
this totalizing prejudice and many
different streams that dissociate from
the body again you can think of plato in
this notion that
real philosophical thought means
contemplating the ideas in this purest
form or let's go to the kind of
cartesian example that eric gave if i
were to enter into room as a good
cartesian
the first thing that i would do would be
to try to rationalize it by putting it
into a grid trying to contemplate the
geometric relations between all the
different objects in there i would do
anything but actually just look at the
objects and ask what do they relate to
me
as right and ponte's emphasis to say no
we have a kind of body image or that's
kinesthetically embedded in everything
that we do and so to try to cartesianize
our understanding of the room by
understanding it in terms of its
geometry et cetera isn't necessarily a
bad thing if that's what you want to do
but to think that that's the way most of
us actually perceive the world when we
enter into a room is just wrong
and because what we should be focused on
in philosophers is our every or day
ordinary experience of the world it's
not what we should be attentive to uh
and to go to eric's other point i also
think he stresses the fact that if we're
going to genuinely be scientific in our
approach to how it is that most of us
actually perceive the world assuming
that we're all good cartesians distorts
um
how it is that most of us actually
apprehended so we have to abandon
that kind of idealization there's a
certain way that ponte does some really
interesting things with those ideas
about geometry
because you know when you when you are
looking at something right it appears
closer or further away
it appears larger smaller than the
things around it we have two eyes right
so we can have a measure of depth
perception yet we don't have to do the
calculations in order to tell how far
away something is or how
like we don't have to do any
calculations about about size and lights
and modeling and light to understand how
far close something is we kind of do
that automatically we take it for
granted but the as as we know about
gestalt psychology is they love to do
experiments and test the limits of
perception and try to present us with
situations where our perception breaks
down where it [ __ ] up where an object
getting
larger looks like it's getting closer
there's a lot of famous sorts of
experiments you can look up on youtube
that come out of gestalt psychology
where it looks at those sort of limit
cases of our perception
where things break down and also sort of
injuries to our brain and nervous system
and what sorts of things break down
after those kinds of things happen to us
which actually gives us a lot of insight
into
how the normal functioning of a mind and
how perception is supposed to work
so those limit cases become very
important and ponte goes into them quite
a bit brings up lots of examples which
is another like sort of just pleasure
about reading his stuff is that loads of
examples loads of very interesting cases
where for instance an object getting
bigger we perceive it as getting closer
but it's actually just getting larger or
maybe the other way around sometimes we
can't tell if you you know if you do one
of those experiments where you're
looking into a box
and there's some objects in it and
they're on stands but the stands are
covered up which one's the closest and
we have a way of doing that sort of just
perceiving looking that one oh that one
there's closest then they reveal the
machinery underneath and it turns out
that one's actually further away or that
weird like illusion room where you look
at a certain angle the room looks
completely normal and and but then
somebody walks into the room and and you
realize the room's all [ __ ] up and and
like on this crazy angle and and the
back of the room is actually like kind
of a
weird shape and not it's not a in other
words it's not a normal room except from
the angle that we see it from those
sorts of experiments are very
interesting in gestalt psychology anyway
and he picks up on them
and he doesn't like those though
i mean he uses them but he doesn't like
do you know that illusion where there's
like something sitting and casting a
shadow on a chess board
and then you say oh well this white is
actually the same color as the black
square in a different part
oh yeah i don't know that one okay like
they say
if you actually knew the color of each
one then you would know that they are
the same color like scientifically
speaking or when there's like a line
optical illusion and he's actually
opposed to these because you're saying
these are actually the same color and
merlot pointy says no no you're changing
the entire context around it
maybe one color's the same if you look
at it in isolation but nothing in the
world
in the phenomenal field actually exists
in isolation so changing the context
actually changes the object
maybe not for maybe not for a photoshop
eyedropper tool
but for a human being it does
uh reminds me actually uh
a couple months ago bacon came onto our
program to talk about her work as a
cognitive scientist and a lot of her
research focuses on this and i remember
when i needed some money i used to
participate in the department of
cognitive science
experiments where they would sit you in
a chair and have you
look at a pathway that seemed to be
moving uh but it was very difficult to
tell whether it was the pathway that was
moving or actually just a ball that was
progressing through a giant pathway uh
and i remember asking yourself which one
is it actually and she said well i can't
tell you because that's the whole thing
we're trying to test what you perceive
it to be uh and in my good cartesian
fashion i just wanted to go smash the
thing being like there must be a good
answer right either the ball is moving
or the room is moving it cannot be both
right
but i think you know merlot ponte is
very helpful in kind of weaning us off
of that temptation by suggesting that
it's not necessarily a matter of
perception in the sense that everything
is relative but that you can study the
way that context frames our perception
of things like motion
and looking at it scientifically and
saying this is actually that and this is
actually that that's just a different
perspective yeah it's not necessarily
the correct perspective by the way i was
right the room was moving the ball was
staying where it [ __ ] was i don't
care what myself says that was the right
answer [ __ ] it congratulations
before we
before we wrap because i want to preview
the rest of what we're going to be
talking about here i want to bring it in
relation to uh social media because we
started off with that
um
because i think it's it's well
documented by a number of opiners
including myself
that there's something that social media
does to our
our
horizon or life world
that is really
toxic to
the way that we expect our minds to be
able to work with the world so i
wondered if anyone had a thought on on
that and what you think merlou ponti can
help us uh return to sanity well i
wonder
well okay well one thing that i thought
about was
uh beaudriard a little bit like so i
think like i wonder i don't know beau
jared well enough and i haven't
definitely haven't engaged with any of
the secondary literature but
i guess i wonder if there's a way of
reading like hyper reality
phenomenologically like uh like i wonder
if there if there's some way of like
think of like making sense of that
concept through like um through a
phenomenological lens that's kind of a
question i mean i don't have an answer
for it but i mean i have another
question too is when when ponte talks
about the um
the phantom limb
is that is that could that be a little
bit like this new phenomenon that
appeared in the news
it's called um mass social media induced
illness
where
where um tourette like
illnesses have been observed in
i guess teenagers or whoever using tick
tock instagram or youtube or other
that's so interesting body media as i
sometimes like to call it because it's
very body focused
that sort of spread of those illnesses
actually kind of follows a similar logic
to
the phantom limb illness where you know
you you you lose a limb but you feel
like it's still kind of there it almost
feels a little bit like that
you
i don't know the the symptoms of
tourette's manifest
in a certain way like the phantom limb
kind of manifests in a person it becomes
it becomes
i don't i don't even know how to talk
about it it becomes part of your
perceptual world i don't i'm i'm not
sure how the yeah the mechanism of
transfers
that's a super interesting idea right so
like i guess
you know that that somehow like the you
know the people who are like live online
a lot like their life world is so like
colored by like ways of engaging through
like online platforms
that then when they like leave uh the
real world it's like they're they're
attuned towards engaging in a similar
way and i guess that you're saying that
maybe it instantiates itself as this
kind of weird tourette's syndrome
yeah no no
we have to we have to read this article
because they are they actually
demonstrate all the symptoms of
tourette's without having you know the
physiological
condition that requires you or that is
required for having tourettes yeah
tourette like symptom is is symptoms is
specifically mentioned and it yeah i
think you might be right like that way
that it conditions us and then we go out
into the world
and we sort of play out those scripts in
a certain way that we learn off of
social media right like
just in the same way that much of our
much of the things we know about are
mediated to us by you know computers and
social media and so our behaviors
towards them are modeled before we even
encounter the objects themselves
and this seems like a weird case of that
where almost like the symptoms of
certain illnesses are manifesting in
people and then they i don't know what
the
the sort of common symptom i guess would
be would be twitching or involuntary
motion
and so well i wonder
i wonder if another way of reading it
too is like
you know but by because i think one of
the things
that like a marilyn ponting account or a
phenomenological account at least one
that focuses on the body it's like
the body needs to be
oriented and configured the body schema
in order for it to like operate properly
in the world basically right so it's
like you know that i think there's like
quite a strong analogy to be made
between skill acquisition
like and just like habits like i think
they're like two sides of the same coin
so like you know being able to engage in
like in like a real social world
requires almost like a kind of skill
acquisition um to be able to like read
other embodied hues of other people
so like perhaps it's not so much that
they're because when you're online like
your body isn't doing anything like i
mean it is obviously but like it's not
you know you're just looking at the
screen
and like in some ways like a lot of
other like kind of
corporeal engagement or whatever is like
is kind of tamped down you're just
sitting there and like you whatever so
so it could not it might not be the fact
that like what's happening is like the
habitual embodied engagement online is
being transferred to the real world but
rather that like the ability to
habitually engage with the real
real world is like somehow
underdeveloped it's like not ready and
then it's like and this is all obviously
speculative but like and then it's like
they're resulting in this symptomatic
twitching because it's like they don't
know how to just like be a body in the
non-cyber world or something i would say
though that your body is doing something
in this circumstance and this is
actually a key point and then i'd like
to move to uh my key theoretical
argument uh because in part you know
there's this there's this implication
that i roll out the carpet the brain is
in some sense it's still disconnected
from the body so if your brain is active
in your body isn't do and the rest of
your body isn't doing anything your body
isn't doing anything and i think that
merlot ponte would stress that actually
the brain is embedded in the body
and functions as part of the body rather
than something disconnected from it so
mental activity is a kind of physical
activity
it's just of a different kind which is
precisely i think why there's this
interconnection between how we're
feeling and what we experience in the
rest of our body and the experiences of
our body and our thought processes but
now to my key theory wait wait wait i
think i can drive that home a little bit
further
to say is to say that
when for instance you know looking at
social media okay whatever or watching a
movie reading a book right i think there
is research out there but i think this
actually
comes from ponte as well is that that
that sort of embeddedness you were
referring to the brain
our minds are embodied right the brain
body environment kind of embodiment
idea and when we're experiencing the
world for instance you go outside and
you pet a dog and
according to this sort of research and
according to merlot ponte who frames it
a certain different way
you you petting the dog is a certain
perceptual experience that you have or
from the neurological perspective it
triggers certain pathways and
neurological reactions in your brain
right and then when you go sit on the
couch and you're watching a show and
that show shows somebody petting a dog
there's evidence that it actually
activates the same sorts of centers in
your brain as if you were physically
doing it we we call that like a kind of
haptic experience right that bodily
involvement in the world and how that
forms the basis of our understanding of
of symbols and images and things like
that as well so again that
that sort of social media phenomenon
where there's this kind of illness being
spread through social media
may have a kind of be conditioning us in
a certain way where we get this
experience in place of having tourette's
we sort of see somebody
performing these involuntary motions and
the same sort of movement centers are
activated in us in a certain way like i
don't know what you call that kind of
[ __ ] mirror neurons or something like
that i don't know but you sort of model
that behavior yourself and then it
becomes pathological in the same sort of
way that when you see an image on the
television of somebody petting a dog or
i don't know you could say even smelling
a i don't know an apple pie on the
television that activates your own
previous experiences of those events
and so there's always
that sort of embodied haptic tactile
sensual involvement even if it seems
like you're at a representational kind
of distance
from what is being represented you have
a bodily involvement in it as well sorry
matt go ahead grand theory time
okay big theory radical question that
we're all dancing around when it comes
to this
is
should you do psychedelics to try to
change your perceptions and as a channel
called plastic pills i think that we
really do need to go negotiate these
questions
and my argument is going to be an
emphatic uh if cautious yes do we have
to do it live
yes you want to just trip just trip on a
live stream
the mushroom episode
everybody gets a different one it's like
all right acid mushrooms somebody else
is going to sit there and do a little
mdma and we're all going to see where we
wind up okay well hopefully none of our
listeners have got tourette's from
tiktok but speaking of phantom limbs and
something that i know
we're all familiar with is phantom ring
or phantom
buzz when you think that your phone is
buzzing
but it wasn't you just made it up in
your head
and there's actually a merlou poncian
explanation for this and that's the
anticipation you're expecting
this thing to happen and it's primed you
to respond to it so you expect it even
if i don't know it scratches your your
leg hair or something and you think your
phone buzzed or you hear
a car outside and it sounds like
uh
your phone is rumbling um and this kind
of it's a silly example that we're all
familiar with but it does
impinge on this
what social media has done to our minds
not not causing tourette's specifically
but how much of your attention it
demands even when it's not buzzing or
dinging or calling your attention to it
it's like the anticipation is always
directed at this little device and even
if that's not causing something as
serious as tourette's symptoms it's
doing something else certainly yeah i
certainly i i have my phone in my pocket
all the time like on my upper thigh area
i get muscle twitches there all the time
it's very strange and then sometimes i
feel like my phone is going off
i mean i don't know it's that kind of
retention into the future of something
strange like when you take your hat off
but you feel like you're still wearing
it for quite a while after you take it
off or when you put it on you know it
feels like you're not wearing it it's
that kind of
that i don't know these these terms are
kind of new to me that sort of
pro-tension retention where you have
the sort of past spilling into the
present but then you sort of have an
anticipation of the future built into
the present as well
it's not just the present as a kind of
simple here and now it's very complex
temporally and so you get those sorts of
effects with social media with
hats with with
phantom limbs and phantom rings and all
that sort of stuff
it's really very interesting i think
vic um yeah just i wanted to quickly add
one one more thing about um
like sort of trying to understand
what the mind is right because you know
i mean we've been talking about phantom
limb and like
earlier there was like referencing of
sort of like you know doing brain scans
and you can see what parts of the of the
mind are activated and i think
you know there's a cognitive i think
he's a cognitive scientist alva noe and
i remember him kind of using this
analogy to say uh
people who want to like over invest the
brain with like where the where you can
find the mind and he's inspired by meryl
laponti by the way and he said something
like trying to understand like what the
mind is by like looking at the brain
is kind of like trying to understand
what money is by just like looking at
the molecules of a dollar bill
and in his point i think there is really
just to say that like to understand what
the mind is actually doing like you you
can't cut off like how it's interacting
with the world like what the world
that's in like that makes it what it is
there's like a reciprocal interaction
between like
mind and world and body and all these
factors
and i think uh similarly like
money obviously is this is like a is
obviously like a a network
object or something that you can't
really explain what it's doing unless
you see what it's doing in a broader
context right i like that i've dipped
into some of that literature and the
this sort of burlo ponte inspired
cognitive science angle and sometimes
it's referred to as an activist theory
or or the extended mind thesis
or the embodied minds there's a couple
different streams and they do have some
differences between them but it seems
like ponte is a broad influence on a lot
of those directions
and i've looked at them a little bit
they're very interesting yeah the
the idea that
you know and i've read this in in in
another theorist named gregory bateson
too the idea that when you take
psychedelics the sort of
that sort of
that
border i guess you call it that
metaphysical division we kind of assume
between our bodies and the worlds around
us kind of disappear he kind of says
we've all we all listen to music right
but when you take acid and listen to
music it feels like you're part of the
song almost you like can't tell the
difference between your own thoughts and
the and the melody
and those sorts of really interesting
things
that that happen um but yeah i think
that that line of cognitive science
that's inspired by ponte is uh
pretty tight
it's promising for sure it's got some
stuff but um
anyway i don't know if oh yeah so merlou
ponte's examples typically have to do
with vision and the gaze and perspective
but
he also applies it to time you could
easily apply it to sonics because it's
supposed to be general
experience
so as a preview of what's tactile stuff
too yeah at the time
and later he's all on touch he says
seeing is a form of touch yeah so yeah
exactly the haptic again that's look up
the word haptic
when you get a chance it's it's kind of
cool we're gonna say haptic a lot but uh
yeah as a as a i guess sort of a preview
or maybe we're we're kind of planning
this out as we go we have a few like
topics
on paper but we're trying to figure out
what is this
uh fold of how our intention just
it becomes reality it's not our reason
that becomes reality it's not our
ability to argue with
anime avis on twitter
but it's uh this
the expectation and i think yeah the
thing that i'm most afraid of even with
my own memory and my own ability to
read
like i used to
is uh notifications they're my they're
my great enemy at this point i have
almost all notifications turned off
except for
when you guys message me but that kind
of expectation that is basically
24 7 expectation of something new um it
it doesn't just ruin
your mind
at the moment that that thing appears
and like
rushes into your day
it's ruining your whole day waiting for
whenever that next thing is and it's not
you consciously waiting it's like the
phantom ring thing your body
your body mind
is waiting for it yep
yeah i think even you know i think even
the word anticipation is almost
i mean i know what you're pointing at
and like i agree with you but i think
you know even the word expectation was
actually the word that you used
expectation i still think even has
an overly cognitive implication to it
like like like i have reason to expect
this thing right it's like right as if
like the reasons for expecting it matter
they don't right like like your body
expects things because of the way your
body's been been been reconfigured
um right i mean it's not the correct
term would be the correct term would be
protection yeah
exactly yeah it's kind of a
preconceptual anticipatory stance
and what we're talking about none of
this occurs consciously from merlou
ponte which is why i think he's like
the best theorist of consciousness is to
say that
like
one percent of your day is conscious
you're not conscious of everything
that's in the room with you right now if
you look around you can only be
conscious of one thing at a time the
size of your ability to focus on
something is like the size of a dime oh
wait we have an international audience
what's uh what's an equivalent
your thought your thumbnail if you hold
your thumbnail out at full length that's
how much space you can actually focus on
everything and everything else everyone
watches american media they all know
what dimes are realistic i just want to
be culturally sensitive to the germans
and the indians
divisions
we took that all from the brit
probably the euro one cent but they
might their sizes might be rational they
might be rationally like associated with
the actual amount of the worth
of the coin as opposed to us where our
dime is smaller than our five cent piece
so rational
their metric system i think they're all
[ __ ] up
a 10p
all right so
anything else you guys uh wanna any any
final questions you want us to think
about before next week well i guess the
only other thing is i would say you can
also anticipate maybe in the future uh
also doing some episodes where like once
we get
this account of phenomenology clear we
might do some episodes where we're like
okay given this how is this
way of thinking about subjectivity being
applied to other fields which could be
interesting so we might look at like how
is it influencing politics or other
things maybe like health care or
something like that so we're like
practical applications of like
how this way of looking at the world
changes like kind of maybe your method
of inquiry depending on what you're
doing because it has influenced a lot of
things like psychology and uh
i went well and obviously like um eric
was talking about um cognitive science
and stuff like that
my my pitch related to that is
what i just reiterate that and and
talking about phenomenology is an
interesting way to sort of maybe make up
for all those social relations and those
sorts of things that have all moved
online and that sort of maybe alienation
you feel
the idea that phenomenology if you apply
it to your own life and try to follow
what ponte and others are are trying to
bring our attention to and trying to get
us to think differently about that they
can perhaps have a salubrious effect on
on
your mental health and your ability to
cope in times of trouble
covet climate change and whatever
economic crisis is next and whatever
sort of
horrible things are going to happen in
the future that
having a phenomenological
grounding in your own experience and an
understanding of it
can be
a kind of i think it could be a kind of
healthy thing it can be very
very um very therapeutic to try to think
about things through the
phenomenological lens because a lot of
a lot of other philosophies tend to be
very abstract
very conceptual
i mean even even historical materialism
and dialectical thinking can be very can
feel alienating in the sense that it's
just
not
down to earth to the degree that
phenomenology is i guess you'd say i
mean it's very down to earth but it
like
i don't know how you do a kind of
phenomenological dialectics of
perception and everyday experience i
don't know if that would be
doable but phenomenology it's got it
it's got it in there you can use it to
ground yourself and maybe get a little
bit closer to
nature and the things around you rather
than relying on
the internet to comfort you or
reruns of friends or whatever other
sorts the paradox is we're just making
more internet content to tell you to
or help you escape from internet to get
off the internet it's not lost on me but
i mean we're telling you something right
we're not just we're not we're not just
going off about something else we say
hey you listener try this at home
maybe not not the drugs not the drugs
part don't cut off your limbs don't try
to test those things but don't the other
don't watch tick-tock
yeah
there's our particular form of of
internet entertainment i think like
we've talked about in the past like the
one like you know silver lining of the
internet culture is like the
proliferation of long-form podcasts
like i think that's one of the few
things that you can point to and be like
that's better than it was before right
like when we were stuck with just like
the couple media conglomerates that were
feeding us like bite-sized [ __ ] because
they didn't think we had the attention
span to like to take up like a long-form
interview podcasts are actually proving
that there is an appetite for that among
a lot of people so or radio shows back
in the day
hey cbc cbc ideas has always been pretty
good
yes but guess what they're government
funded right so they're they're getting
paid to make stuff that is educational
and like and stuff so like
yeah but maybe maybe you'll be listening
to this maybe outside of your drive to
work if that's all the most common time
you listen to radio and television maybe
you just throw this on or throw on some
kind of lecture or something and you go
for a walk instead and you
you
take it with you into the world instead
of just doing it on the commute or doing
it which is okay too but
maybe maybe kovit has created some more
space for you to fill up with your own
interests and your own kinds of
time
based activity for me it's uh
for me it's commuting well i guess
whatever going like biking somewhere or
taking the subway somewhere or cooking
is when i listen to podcasts wait so now
we're like a healthy living podcast
i'm just we're just gonna
we're just going to transition into a
lifestyle podcast
hey if jordan peterson gets to pitch all
of his
grandiose theories as self-help books
then i think
i think we're justified to do it and we
can do it better than he can
all right episode one if you're an
extrovert listen to us
episode one of how phenomenology will
save your very soul
perfect looking forward to the rest of
the episodes
alright
take care guys
peace
[Music]
you